The Joe Rogan Experience this is
something I wanted to talk to you about
um Trump vs DeSantis in 2024
who's the favorite who do you think wins
I don't know do you think that happens
it seems like they're they're
positioning that right let's see but
wouldn't the ultimate be they combine
they combine forces but if DeSantis is
never going to do that you don't think
so no Trump's ego he would never team up
he's already been [__] on him for
the past like month yeah but he [__] on
people before and brought him into the
fold think about all the [__] that he
said to Ted Cruz and all those other
people yeah but the difference is Ted
Cruz cucked himself to Trump so Ted bent
the knee after a while and what happened
was that was actually a really
interesting story so he went to the RNC
and he said vote your conscience which
basically was like he wasn't endorsing
Trump he was saying do whatever you want
I'm like I'm not endorsing him then he
got a phone call from his billionaire uh
donor daddy Robert Mercer I think his
name is and he was like
remember who you work for
and so Ted fell in line and then he was
phone banking for Trump with that
Weasley face on like yeah vote for
Donald Trump and so he fell in line he
fell in line and so I I don't think
Santa's not gonna do that I mean
if if he's smart I don't think he would
look if you had a straight-up race just
Trump versus DeSantis I actually think
DeSantis could win that but the problem
for DeSantis is this there's already a
bunch of other [__] who nobody cares
about who are jumping in the race who
are going to get two percent three
percent and that all comes out of
desantis's numbers and not Trump's
numbers so if you have a race with 10
different Republicans nine of them are
not Donald Trump nine of them are
splitting the non-donald Trump vote and
there's one Trump who can win with 29
percent of the vote or something like
that which is likely which is like Nikki
Haley she seems like she's gonna run
she's a [__] total donor creation
nobody gives a [__] about her she's been
told by rich people yeah you're the one
go ahead she's gonna get destroyed right
but she runs Mike Pompeo he wants to run
uh John Bolton he wants like all these
people are gonna run and then if you
have all of them and DeSantis and Trump
you're handing it over to Trump the
other Republicans we need to get in a
room behind closed doors talk it out and
say look we all have egos here but we
got to put it aside and they should dull
stuff out DeSantis could say all right
who wants to be Secretary of State who
wants to be vice president Let's Make a
Deal so I'm the only one running against
him because that's the only way they're
going to take him down do you think
that's how how it goes I don't because
they don't have that level of
organization they don't and and you have
a whole bunch of giant egos so I think
what's likely is they all run and Trump
wins with like 30 percent of the vote
because you know it's first past the
post voting if he gets 30 and then
closest to him is 21 or whatever the
[__] drug wins and it's in the primary
so it's all registered Republicans
correct correct so it's an it's an
interesting situation and Crystal and I
and Sagar as well we've been having this
debate back and forth because there was
a period there after the midterm loss
where there were a bunch of polls
showing DeSantis up comfy on trump it
was like DeSantis it by double digits
right and we were having the debate
where I was like no I think DeSantis is
the favorite he is the favorite but now
just recently new three or four polls
came out Trump's back up double digits
and so it could be a heavyweight slug
Fest but also
I don't I don't know if he has the balls
to like Jump Right In and take him on
you know what I mean because he is The
Heir Apparent he is like Diet Donald
Trump in a sense so he probably he might
feel like if I just wait till 2028 I I
could probably win it but his moment is
now right because in the midterms the
candidates that were most trumpy were
the ones who lost so Carrie Lake she was
denying the election left and right she
was one of Trump's favorites she lost
Doug mastriano ran for governor in
Pennsylvania he lost and he was but he
was at January 6th he was a big time
election tonight like all the election
deniers all the ones who really cuddled
up to Trump those are the ones who lost
the more the more like old school
Republicans like uh Kemp in Georgia who
and he's a guy who said to Trump
remember Trump said find me 11 000 votes
after 2020. yes that's the guy who was
like no I'm not going to do that and
that guy won his election easy in
Georgia so basically the more non-trump
Republicans did better and so you know
there's a real real weakness there and
he was siled off on Truth social for a
while he wasn't like he sort of lost his
Norm me touch a little bit you know what
I mean he was getting too too wacky and
so DeSantis was The Heir Apparent but
now things are changing do you think
that Trump comes back to all those
social media platforms like what is this
I've read something about his deal with
true social that it might be up soon oh
I if that's true that's interesting I
did read that he's planning on coming
back to both Facebook and Twitter I did
read that but to your point yeah my
understanding was he had a deal with
truth so the whole value of the company
is tied to Trump being on it and so he
pulls out of that he's pissing off a lot
of people who invested a lot of money in
that company which you know he's done
[__] like that in the past so I don't
see why he wouldn't do it now but look
he kind of needs it he needs to be back
on Twitter he needs to be back on
Facebook right because if he's on
Twitter that's where people are going to
go DeSantis so because I know you were
also a fan of Bernie yes and they're
like Polar Opposites in terms of the
rest of their own I'm a fan of them for
different reasons right yeah but I know
you said that you thought he would make
a good president and there's a bunch of
things about him that uh I think would
probably change your opinion on it like
for example he thinks weed should stay
illegal because it smells bad
is that really his opinion that it
smells bad he said it's not know about
Edibles putrid and he wants it to stay
bad because of that oh that's hilarious
is that really is it's rationalization
Jamie if you want you could pull that up
yeah that's what it says here but it's
legal in Florida automatically medically
it says marijuana should remain
criminalized because of its putrid odor
polling compiled by the University of
North Florida showed that most
Floridians want the adult use of
marijuana to be legal in sunshine state
that's certainly not the case in fact
under state law the possession of up to
20 grams of cannabis is punished by a
thousand dollars fine up to year in
prison possession of Greater Amounts is
a felony so what does he said what I
don't like about is if you go to some of
these places that have done it the
stench when you're out there I mean it
smells so putrid I want people to be
able to breathe freely well that's silly
yeah but that's also like like I want to
know the context um what I want to I
want I mean that's a quote
the smell of marijuana DeSantis the
mirrors on marijuana legalization but
can't stand the Dank stank well okay you
don't have to like the smell
you know I mean I mean that doesn't
necessarily mean that's why he wants it
illegal he just doesn't like the smell a
lot of people don't like the smell but
it's not legal there recreationally
right no not yet no no it's not legal
here either would he sign the bill is
the question you know
and it seems to me like you would
because he's a social conservative by
and large you know like that's his
perspective another one is he uh they
had a vote in Florida direct vote on
raising the minimum wage during the 2020
election and so Trump won the state
but 60 percent of Florida voters
voted for a minimum wage increase they
wanted to make it 15. and leading into
that DeSantis said don't do that I'm
against doing that did he have a
rationalization uh
I mean I didn't see if he did but just
the fact he's against it was a strike
against him in my mind but it did the
voters voted for it and that is the law
so because they had the direct vote and
I don't know if he has any legal
recourse so it's becoming law but he
told them don't don't vote for it so
that was a big issue because I know
you're a fan of legal weed you're a fan
of raising the minimum wage
um he's also a big Wall Street guy I
mean a lot of these Republicans you
don't have to look too far under the
surface to find out they're all playing
the same game game he took 20 million
from Wall Street he did uh 5.7 billion
dollars in tax cuts and giveaways to
corporations apparently 99 of companies
in Florida pay no corporate income tax
so it's one of the states that
corporations go to sort of you know it's
a field day over there
um
and remember he was feuding with Disney
man when he's shooting with Disney and
he was like you know you guys are
[__] woke and this has got to stop
but he let them keep a 578 million
dollar tax break at the same time
and at that same time he also did a one
billion dollar tax hike on regular
Floridians with a new sales tax well the
the amount of business that Disney must
be bringing into Florida is insane right
I mean they own Orlando which is all the
reason they don't need more of a subsidy
right like let them [__] it don't don't
be able to swim they're not gonna sink
like let him let him be what do you
think that is do you think there's just
some Financial chicanery some behind the
scenes I think if you're the governor of
Florida and you know how big Disney is
you might talk a game every now and then
of like yeah we don't you know we don't
like these guys or whatever they're too
woke but when push comes to shove I
don't remember in regard to the woke
thing I don't recall it was a very
specific instance yeah I don't either I
don't remember it either but there was a
there was he had a big fight with them
but ultimately he gave them their tax
break and then the other thing is so
there's a big sugar cane industry in
Florida and they lead to a lot of
pollution because they do these things
called burn Fields as part of the
process involved with the sugar cane and
um he came in and shielded them from any
legal accountability so people can't sue
them yeah so and the Florida Republican
party took a 350
000 contribution from the sugarcane
industry and then in turn he
protected them from legal liability and
when you're saying pollution this is
particulates in the atmosphere because
of the burning yeah they say that
because of those uh sugarcane burn
Fields there's increased risk of cancer
and red tide have you ever heard of red
tide in Florida that's the ocean red
time yeah there's some weird ocean red
tide thing apparently the sugar cane
burning of the sugar cane helps lead to
that as well along with like you said
the particular matter which could lead
to cancer
the the burning of it that's like a
common agricultural approach right where
they they do they do that to sort of uh
re-vigorize the that's not a word but
the
um the soil right the topsoil is that
what they're doing I mean there's some
industrial reason why they do it but I
think there was conversation around hey
we got to regulate this we have to make
it uh you know we got to lower the
cancer rate we got to lower the red tide
we got to figure this out and there's a
direct correlation between those Burns
and cancer cancer instances yeah there's
a lot of health problems around those
things yeah
hmm
yeah so there's there's uh he's he's
quite the opposite of Bernie I think
he's very he's
he's an establishment Republican who's
good at
PR basically I think he's positioned
himself so there's there's two parts of
politics there's politics and there's
policy on the politics front I think
he's actually plotted his way around
brilliantly where you know he is The
Heir Apparent to Donald Trump and
there's a chance he could even beat
Donald Trump in a in a Republican
primary
um and honestly I think any Democrat
should fear him over Trump in a general
election I think even half-dead Joe
Biden can can defeat Trump again I do
yeah yeah well to see the problem is
Trump has siled himself off and he's he
can't shut up about the 2020 election
it's still in his you know and it's he
comes across as whiny and the
Republicans under his leadership got
wiped out in the 2018 midterms they got
wiped out in the 2020 uh main election
and they got wiped out in the 2022
midterms well people either love him or
they hate him and I don't think that
there's as much polarity
that's right DeSantis has a much better
chance of gaining back some of the
moderates that kind of fled yeah when
they just want conservative economic
policies right yeah and so uh so I think
he's a he would be a good general
election candidate but in terms of how
he governs it would be
George W bush it would be George H.W
bush it would be Trump it'd be all the
same stuff tax cuts for the wealthy
super serve Wall Street keep the
military industrial complex going
um who do you like if Biden drops out uh
the only person I'm interested in at the
moment is Marianne Williamson because
there's some chatter about she might
primary Joe Biden and I would love that
because look the problem with Biden
there's a lot of problems with Biden but
like ideologically the problem is he has
no Grand Vision right like there is no
here's what I'm trying to do here's what
I'm trying to get to here's the ideal
it's very like I call him a status quo
manager it's like I'll do some tweaks
around the edges here and there we'll
make some things a little bit better
here and there but he's also dead right
like he's a zombie yeah and then you
have Marianne Williamson who I think she
she would run in the spirit of FDR she
would say we got to go back to the
Democratic party used to be the workers
party it used to look out for people and
we need to get back to that so we need
to do things like Universal Health Care
we need to do things like Universal
education we need to have higher wages
and and that's more my politics so right
now she's the only one I'm interested in
there's a decent chance that she
challenges Biden and I think that'll be
interesting for this reason
um
polls show over 60 percent of Democrats
are like we don't we're done we're done
with this yeah we gotta wait come on we
gotta move on from this what do you do
you buy into this idea that that's one
of the reasons why they keep filing
these classified documents
oh see I'm trying to push him I think
it's incompetence to be honest really I
think you have a it's a it's a fun
Theory like it's interesting to think
about right
um but I think the Democratic
establishment kind of realizes that
they need him because Kamal is worse
mayor Pete is worse yeah these are
people who are more unpopular than Biden
yeah they would rather take a half dead
Joe Biden than take one of those and
roll the dice what about Newsome
Newsome so Newsome is plotting like he
wants to run but he would never primary
Biden she's a good little Democrat and
he'll fall in line and go through the
process and he'll think 2028 is my time
that's what he'll think but you know a
lot of these people are secretly waiting
in the wings for Biden to croak and then
he would step in absolutely absolutely
it could happen and then then do some
would run in 2024. so but he's he's
trying to you know he's starting to Edge
his way in there which and again for him
I think he he would have a better chance
than a Kamala or a mayor Pete but I
still think he's
he's got the slimy politician feel to it
there's a lot of stuff to pick part in
his record as you accurately pointed out
I mean there's just
look this is the era of the outsider
it's the hour of the outsider Trump ran
as an outsider he won right Biden was
the return to normal guy like okay a
strong guy's getting a little crazy
let's go back in this direction but it's
still the era of the outsider there's
people still want something fresh
something different something from
outside of the political system to come
in and bring about real change
it's not like politics used to be where
it's like if you're the most buttoned up
if you're the most clean if it's your
turn then it's your turn now it's more
like holy [__] this is [__] crazy all
hell's breaking loose let's get some
people with good ideas in there who
actually smart